Hi there, Steve Kaufman here again,
and I want to talk again about
ChatGPT, artificial intelligence
and its impact on language learning.
You know, I enjoy doing these videos.
Uh, some people say, you know,
you always say the same thing,
you're a big bag of wind, whatever.
I don't mind, people are
entitled to their opinions.
Uh, but I do enjoy doing these
videos and sharing my ideas
with you, and I get feedback.
One person said, you know, the effect
of GPT is going to, to render all the
language learning apps, uh, irrelevant.
Uh, there's also fear on the part
of some that it'll, uh, you know,
affect the role of the teacher.
I don't think it should.
Uh, and I'm gonna explain why.
So, if I look at Duolingo, which
has, uh, apparently incorporated some
aspects of ChatGPT in their system,
I don't fully know how, and, and, and
all the details, but I, I looked it up
on the, on, you know, Google and what
they're incorporating is essentially
role playing and error correction.
So yeah, it's possible that, um, a
person could sort of individually set
up role playing activities with ChatGPT.
Uh, and in these role playing activities,
ChatGPT could also correct whatever it
is that they type in to their, you know,
dialogue with ChatGPT, uh, independently.
Uh, a learner could, could
write an essay or whatever and
have it corrected by ChatGPT.
So does that make the teacher unnecessary?
I don't think so.
I think we have to look at...
and, and by the way, I saw on some of the
websites that I visited, the suggestion
that well, uh, you know, ChatGPT may
lighten the load for teachers or might
make it, you know, less necessary to go
to, uh, you know, uh, substitute teachers.
This idea that there's this hierarchy
of established teachers, permanent
teachers, and substitute teachers,
I don't see a big difference between
them, because basically the role of
the teacher is to motivate the learner.
The classroom is largely a social place.
It's where people meet, it's where
the students meet each other.
It's where the teacher meets the students.
In an ideal scenario, out of this
classroom environment comes an
enthusiasm for learning the language.
That's what happened to me, not the 10
years that I did French school, where
the classroom was just boring, but when
in first year university at McGill,
I had a professor that made French
civilization so fascinating for me
that I decided to really pursue French.
So that's an example of the vital
role that a teacher can play, and it's
possible with ChatGPT because ChatGPT
can generate, uh, content, can correct
things, provide a motivated learner with
some opportunity for, you know, studying
on his or her own, having his or her
material corrected, or maybe before
submitting an essay, having it corrected.
Or in the worst case, having
ChatGPTwrite the essay for him or
her, which I gather they're looking
at ways of, you know, making that more
difficult to do without being detected.
So some of these opportunities are there,
but the teacher, whether substitute
or the main tenured teacher, call it,
still has this tremendously important
social role because language is social.
Language is communicating.
Communicating with people, communicating
with history, communicating with
sound, communicating with the written
word, and it's up to the teacher to
make that motivating, interesting.
And, and certainly as an independent
learner, I would not use ChatGPT
for correcting my writing.
I have no interest in that.
Um, my use of the language
will be what it is.
It'll gradually improve as I talk
to people, as I hear how the native
speaker uses the language, as I listen
to content of interest I expect that
my vocabulary will grow, my familiarity
with the language will, uh, increase
and, uh, the frequency of my areas
will gradually, you know, diminish.
Um, but I know from experience
that being corrected doesn't mean
that I get it right the next time.
So it's just, you know, yeah, if...
I'll do what I feel like doing in the
language and that probably will not
include an essay for ChatGPT to correct.
I am personally also not interested
in having a role playing exercise
with a ChatGPT, however, I can see
where a teacher could assign that.
Uh, and therefore the ChatGPT then is
a resource available to the teacher to,
you know, assign an activity, say role
playing or interacting with ChatGPT.
Or, uh, asking a student to write
something for ChatGPT to correct,
which therefore means that the
teacher doesn't have to correct it.
So there are all these ways
in which ChatGPT becomes, uh,
uh, an assist to the teacher.
Even though it's not a great interest
to an independent learner like me, it
enables the teacher to, uh, you know,
achieve what the curriculum requires
the teacher to do in the classroom.
But fundamentally, the
teacher to me is a mo...
a motivator, and I don't think ChatGPT
is gonna remove or substitute for
the need for a teacher to motivate
learners, but it can be used by a
teacher to lighten their load in terms
of correction, in terms of dreaming up
role playing situations, uh, and for the
truly independent learner like myself,
probably not all that relevant in those
roles, in the roles that dual lingo has
decided to, you know, assign to cChatGPT.
However, where I am more optimistic
is, is using ChatGPT to help
generate, you know, learner content
at, particularly at the intermediate
or beginner, intermediate level.
Uh, but even then, as I've said before,
we need to consume so much content and
ultimately we want to have compelling,
interesting content, authentic content.
And so ChatGPT would have a limited role.
Uh, I am much more interested in seeing
how we can use Whisper or some of this
other technology to facilitate the
transcription of the massive amount of
excellent compelling audio content that
exists and how we can better integrate
that into a, you know, uh, a learning
platform light LingQ with our sentence
view, maybe better timestamping.
These kinds of things to facilitate
or to make it more efficient and
more compelling for learners and
make it easier for learners to access
more difficult content using the
functionality that we have at LingQ.
So those are the kinds of applications
that I see for AI call it, or maybe, uh,
improved, uh, text to speech where we
don't notice the difference between the,
uh, natural voice and text to speech.
Those are some of the things
that I'm more hopeful.
Uh, to me at least as an independent
learner, I think ChatGPT has
more limited application.
However, I can see where it can, uh,
lessen the burden of language teachers.
So a little bit of a, you know, a
meandering piece there on ChatGPT
again, and, and, and whether it
will actually threaten, uh, language
learning apps as one of my viewers
suggested, like LingQ for example,
or threaten the role of teachers.
So I hope you found, you found that
interesting and uh, you can have a
look at some of the other discussions
on this subject that I've had.
Bye for now.